The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOE HADZIMA: OK.
The second part of
tonight is going
to deal with legal issues.
And the first thing I
have to caution you on
is-- whoops, what happened.
I take that back.
I didn't start at the beginning.
This is background for education
only and it's not legal advice.
Have to say that.
One of the things is that law
stuff is very fact specific.
So anything that I
tell you here now
could change based on the facts.
And the law could change too.
What I'm going to do is
go through an awful lot
of slides covering a whole
bunch of areas of law
related to startups.
And I put on a
website-- the Deck.
You can get that
now if you want.
What I'd like you to
do is I'm going to try
to point out the big issues.
And at the end of the day,
it's more like an issue
spotting thing.
Will you recognize things
as you encounter them
so that you have a
framework to have
a discussion with
your legal adviser,
with your team, et cetera.
So we're going to go
to a pretty good clip.
I'll try to take questions
but I reserve the right
to sort of push through.
So it's about legal issues.
I'll see if I get
this thing working.
Sorry.
First of all, do we have
any lawyers in the audience?
Uh-oh.
One lawyer.
OK.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE] came up
with this great idea
that I did last year--
is to take the life
cycle of the business and to
look at it through various sets
of layers here.
Starting with intellectual
property, legal entity, people,
and financing.
And across from pre- idea stage
all the way through financing.
So we're going to
walk through that.
And the first stage is going
to be the intellectual property
stage.
And it's the idea part.
And the question is who
owns the IP for the venture.
And then the pre-
outside financing
is, how do you protect that.
So that's the theme
for this part.
Now how do we relate
to a business plan.
And this is Fiona
Murray's Four Key Ideas
for Startups The first is
controlling the knowledge
underlying an invention.
If that's important to
your business success,
that's one of the
keys to startup.
The second is secrecy.
Maybe nobody else knows
exactly how you do what you do.
The third is speed.
Even with that other stuff
you need to move quickly.
And that could be a real
key advantage-- an idea.
And the fourth
thing-- in thinking
about intellectual
property-- is there a way
you could lock in customers.
The way you go
about dealing with
your intellectual property.
And then how can that help
you in your business plan.
Well first of all, IP
is a valuable asset
and you can use it
to raise capital.
One of the issues
with a lot of IP
is the investors don't
really understand what it is.
But they think it's important.
And so if you don't
have some, they're
going to be questioning,
why aren't you
doing something there.
So it's really a combination
of, is this important to you
and have you thought about it.
Now there is correlation
between IP and success.
I did a study-- it was published
in the Intellectual Asset
Management publication-- in
which we run these analyzes
on venture backed companies.
We run about 9,000 companies
through the set of metrics.
And we took five top funds.
Kleiner Perkins, New
Enterprise, Domain-- and we
looked at patents
and we said, if we
were to try to figure out
which companies had IP
and how good was their IP and
what was there success rates.
We look at the
portfolios and said,
well we know some companies
have been acquired
or they've gone public.
Those are winners.
And some companies
are out of business.
They failed.
And then a bunch of
the other companies--
we don't know where
they are from a thing.
And what we did is we
looked at our rankings
based on analyzing IP.
And it turned out to 86%
of the winners scored high
in their patent strategy.
Which is sort of
interesting when you think.
The Kleiner Perkins success
rate is one out of three.
That is one out of
every three investments
that they make turns
out to be a success.
And they've got the best
track record out there.
So IP can really
correlate with success.
The other thing
people look at is
you can establish that
you are a good manager
of your technology.
And that can help you in
on your business plan.
Now I'm going to run two
different types of IP
protection, starting with none.
And then trademark, copyright,
trade secret, patent,
and combination.
Now trademark and
copyright-- I'll
get into more detail--
but basically these
are things that can
enhance your value.
But they don't
necessarily block others
from doing what you're doing.
Whereas trade secret
can prevent others.
If they don't know how you
do it, they can't do it.
And then patent is sort
of a combination of both.
Because in order to get
a patent, as you'll see,
you have to actually
disclose what you're doing.
So you're telling
people the secret sauce
but you get some
rights in return.
And then in some cases you get
combinations of protections.
Like software can be protected
by copyright and by patent.
So trademarks, what
are these things.
Well basically a
trademark is-- it can
be a name, a symbol, a sound.
Harley Davidson
actually trademarked
the sound of the vroom vroom.
Color pink for insulation
is Owens Corning.
And what it is--
it's something that
tells a consumer that you're the
source of that good or service.
So if I say Mercedes-Benz, you
have an image of what it is.
So it connects the customer
with a particular source.
And it can be all
sorts of things.
It can be a house
mark, which would
be IBM or Virtual Inc, which
is sort of the company names.
It can be a product mark.
Like ThinkPad used to be IBM.
Now a Lenovo product.
And Mimio was the
virtual ink one.
The rights you get from
trademark arise through use.
And if you register it you
get a whole bunch of benefits.
And it's not very
expensive process to do it.
You should use a fanciful name.
So who would have thought
Apple for a computer.
That's a strong mark.
Don't pick something
that's merely descriptive,
like storage technology or
analog devices as a mark.
And for the business plan, if
you're putting it together,
you can actually check on
the availability of a mark
by going to the USPTO and you
can search for a mark name.
Any questions on that so far?
OK, so the next
one is copyright.
So copyright is
basically the right
to prevent others from
making copies of what you do.
And it rises just
from creating a work.
So if I write a
letter to my mother,
I have a copyright in that.
Federal registration
is a plus in terms
of the ability to enforce that.
It protects the expression,
not the function.
So I can actually copyright
my exact code in software.
But I can't, through copyright,
prevent somebody else
from looking at the
code and writing
equivalent kind of things, as
long as they are not exactly
copying it.
Now for a business
plan, the key thing
with copyright that people
trip over is who owns it.
The owner of a copyright
is the author of the work,
be it software, a
document, or whatever.
It's the author.
Now unless that
author is an employee
and is generating that in
the course of employment.
So if you go and hire an
independent contractor
to write code for
you, don't own it,
even though you paid for it.
And so you've got
to make sure you
have an assignment of
ownership of that work to you.
Or when the investors
come in and they
do their due diligence,
they're going to say,
you don't actually own it.
I had a case back
in my law days where
someone paid over a half
million dollars for code
and couldn't actually
get ownership of it
because he hadn't protected it.
And I also mentioned here, look
at open source as an issue.
Where you're using
open source, make
sure you're complying with
the license for open source.
Because investors, when they
come in-- you do all this work,
you do your pitch.
They send in the troops
to look you over then
they find these landmines
you've planted there
that you could have avoided.
So keep that in mind.
Now trade secret
is what it says.
It's a secret it's something
that gives you, hopefully,
an unfair competitive advantage
that nobody else knows
how to do.
And the most famous one is
the formula for Coca Cola.
Which, I don't know whether
chemically you could figure it
out-- apparently nobody has.
But that's an example.
It's been a secret
for a long time.
I should back up.
A copyright is
effectively a long time.
It's like 75 years.
Trademark is indefinite as
long as you keep renewing it.
Trade secret is indefinite
until it's finally
out there in the world.
So you protect trade
secrets through
non-disclosure
agreements, if you're
going to actually
have to describe it,
or you just don't
tell people about it.
I think I'll just
leave it at that point
The sort of big gorilla in
the IP spaces is patents.
Because they have much
stronger rights that you get.
They're more expensive to get,
but they're stronger rights.
So a patent is really a
limited time monopoly.
And we don't really like
monopolies in the US.
We have antitrust laws.
But in this case--
societal benefit,
it goes right back
to the Constitution.
It says, look, we're going
to get ahead as a society
if an inventor will
tell us how he did it.
And in exchange, we'll give
the inventor a limited time
monopoly to prevent others
from doing something.
It has to be applied for.
In the US, that's with
the patent office.
These patents are
country by country.
In fact, most of these IP
rights are country by country.
Now, what do you get.
Well, it's very much
like real estate.
The fundamental
right-- and we'll
go into a little more
detail in a moment--
is the right to prevent
people from trespassing
on your invention.
So if you own a
piece of real estate,
your fundamental
right is, if I own
it and you walk on my
property, I can kick you off.
Call the police,
get off my property.
And that's essentially
what a patent does.
The way it does that is
you could prevent others
from making, using, selling,
importing, and distributing
your invention.
So you can't take something
that's patented in the US,
take it to a third, a
second, another country,
make it and bring
it back into the US.
That would be an infringement.
Now the ownership of a patent
is not necessarily the right
to use it.
That's a hard one
to think about.
What does that mean.
Well, think about real estate.
If my fundamental right
is, I can keep you
from walking on my
land, does that mean
I can actually use my land.
Well, maybe not.
Suppose I have to walk across
your land to get to my land.
I might not actually
be able to use my land
but I can certainly
keep you off of it.
And so that's the analogy.
Some people think that
it's a right to use.
It's really a right to exclude.
And the claims in the
patent are like the fence
around the property.
So those to find what
the legal property
is that you can
keep people out of.
And the duration is
20 years from the date
of filing under the new rules.
Now what do you have
to do to get a patent.
It has to be
something new, novel.
And to get it, you have
to show the examiner.
You make a filing
with the patent office
and you have to
tell the examiner
how yours is different from
what else is out there.
Let's call prior art.
So you have to cite prior art.
So it has to be useful, also.
That's not really an
issue for most patents.
There's some pretty
un-useful things that
have been patented out there.
It has to be patentable
subject matter, which
is this whole thing we're
seeing now with business method
patents that I won't
go into any detail on.
And it can't
previously have been
sold or publicly described.
In the US you have
a one year window
from the time you publicly
describe your invention
or you put on the
market for sale.
You have one year in which you
get an application on file.
And if you don't, you won't be
able to get a patent at all.
Now the public description has
to be an enabling description.
So it has to be something
that actually explains it.
So if I stood here
and said, I've
got this invention for
anti-gravity boots,
I haven't told you anything
about how it's done.
So it has to be enabling.
Now the other
requirement is that what
you're trying to patent has
to be not obvious to one
of ordinary skill in the art.
Now the word is ordinary
skill in the art.
I had a MIT professor
who decided, well,
this was sort of-- anybody
could have figured this out.
Because he was used to dealing
at MIT professor level.
And so I said, I'm not sure.
You better go check
with a patent lawyer.
And sure enough, it was
not something anyone
with an ordinary skill would
have been able to figure out.
Examples of overcoming that
part is that the prior art
teaches against it.
Other people say
it can't be done.
And you've shown it or
its commercial success.
Bob Langer does a
great story about some
of his early patents,
where he came in and showed
the examiner.
Look, if it was so obvious,
how come nobody else did it.
Nobody else.
And here are some papers
that said it can't be done.
And that's how he overcame
his original set of issues.
I hear a question?
OK.
In the back, yes.
AUDIENCE: Not previously sold.
Does that mean not previously
sold by anyone else?
Or can you not sell it
until you have the patent?
JOE HADZIMA: Let me go back.
I said it was one
year in the US.
I should also mention in
the rest of the world,
if you disclose or offer
for sale before you file,
you won't be able to get a
patent in any other country.
AUDIENCE: One year is
from the first time you--
JOE HADZIMA: Either publicly
disclose or hold out for sale.
Yeah.
And there are a lot of nuances
on the hold out for sale.
The purpose of
going through this
is I want you know sort of
what the general issues are.
And so you'll think about it.
Oh, maybe we ought
to get that-- if we
want to have a
patent, maybe we ought
to go talk to someone before
we take it to a demo day
and blow our chances.
AUDIENCE: So does public
disclosure include things
like telling your peers in a lab
or telling students in a class?
And also, if you
[INAUDIBLE] use an object
in [INAUDIBLE]
without revealing how
one goes from input to
output-- is that a disclosure?
JOE HADZIMA: All right.
So the question is,
is a public disclosure
if you talk to your
lab mates or you do it
in the confines of
an academic setting.
Sort of a closed
kind of setting.
And in general,
yes, but you want
to be very careful about that.
It's one of those facts and
circumstances type things.
There is an exception
to the holding
out for sale for experimental
use of something.
But again, the point
here is you don't
want to rely on
these after the fact.
You want to, if you're planning
some activities where you think
it's really important
about a patent,
make sure you know what the
exact rule is at that time.
Because it could change
next week with a court case.
These are just red
flag type things.
AUDIENCE: What about
the second half?
Where if you're
demoing something
but you give no indication of
what it's worth [INAUDIBLE].
JOE HADZIMA: So the question
is, if you're demoing something
and you don't explain how it
works, is that a disclosure.
It's actually been held
that way in some cases.
Where you actually couldn't
see the actual device.
So again, my point
is, think about ahead
of time and with
the given facts,
make sure you get some good
advice before you go off
and do it and then wish you had
thought about it ahead of time.
OK.
So let me keep moving.
Oops, let's see.
Same issue from a
business plan viewpoint.
Do you actually
own the technology.
So a patent issues in
the name of an inventor.
And a company only gets it
if the inventor assigns it.
So if you're a technical person,
you go work for a company,
you probably end up signing
an invention disclosure
agreement and an assignment.
So if you invent something
in the course of your work,
you agree the employer owns it.
And if you're a startup
and you hire people,
you want to have something
along those lines also.
You could in-license
from the university.
I'll tell you a little bit about
MIT and how it works there.
And did you let it go
into the public domain.
In other words, did you screw
up these one year rules.
OK.
Now obtaining a patent
involves sort of four steps.
In Determining what to patent.
Determining when to file.
You got to prepare
the applications.
And then you've got
to prosecute it,
which means you negotiate
with the Patent Office
about getting a patent.
And that can take several years.
Determining what the patent
really is more about not
what can I get a patent on.
Its what's useful.
Because patents are
pretty expensive.
And you probably don't
have enough money
to patent everything
you actually invent.
And when you say, what do
I want to get a patent on,
you say, well, what
value does it add.
Remember we talked about we
want to create value-- that's
part of the mission here.
If I patent this,
is it valuable.
Does it create commercial value.
Does it prevent
competitors from using it.
And in determining whether
it has commercial value
or not, or whether you can
easily get a patent on it,
you want to compare
against the prior art.
So this is where I get to do
a little pitch for the company
that I founded called IP Vision.
We were doing early stage
technology commercialization
out of MIT.
And the problem we had doing
the same kind of things
we're talking about
in class-- market,
time to market, what's the
strategy-- is we always
had a problem
figuring out what's
the intellectual property.
And the only way we
could really do it
was try to read a ton of patents
or send it out to a law firm.
And we get back a
real thick report.
It was perfectly accurate,
but not very helpful.
So we invented our own way
to map out the IP space.
And this is an example
of our landing page.
The free version is
at see-the-forest.com,
with hyphens in-between there.
There's a free version.
And for people in
the MIT community,
we give free upgrades to
premium while you're working
on your plans and stuff.
So check it out
and I'll show you
an example of what
it looks like.
This is Virtual Inks, one
of its key first patents.
And this is a patent map.
The horizontal axis is time.
The patent is here.
Each of these boxes
is aligned in time,
with the left edge being
the issue date and the tail
being the filing date.
And this is a single
patent landscape
map when they started off.
And these are the citations.
So this patent cited all these
other patents as prior art
in the course of
the examination.
So by looking at these maps
you can see who's in the space
and see what's going on.
You can right click on the
system on any of the boxes
and get the underlying
information.
The statistics boxes on the
map shows you who's on the map
so you can see quickly
who's in the space.
And this is what this patent
looked like several years
later.
So when it issued,
of course nobody
else was citing it because
these are not publicly
disclosed back in this
day-- until it was issued.
Over time, other things started
to cite Yonald's patent.
So it's an example of
something where you can quickly
look at it and check it out.
And if you have any questions,
let me know on that.
This is what the Virtual Ink
US portfolio looked like it
when it had 12 patents.
And you can see these
are some of patents.
And you can start to see
other companies citing.
So these are potential
partners, customers.
It can also help you,
as you try to figure out
as you look at a
space, where do you
want to take the
commercialization plan.
So check it out let me know
if you have any questions.
OK, so the question
is when to file.
Before you lose rights.
So that's the whole thing about
if you do a public disclosure
and you want to get a patent in
France or Germany or something,
and you haven't filed
already somewhere,
you're going to lose that.
And then you want
to take into account
we have new domain now called
the America Invents Act.
Before, it used to be in the
US, that the first to invent won
in a dispute between inventors.
Under the new rules that
came into effect this year,
it's the first to file.
Which is actually a
tougher one for startups
because you'd like to not
encounter all of that cost
for filing until
you actually get
an idea that it's a good idea.
But you could lose the
race to the Patent Office.
So it makes a little harder
on startups these days.
A way to deal with the
high cost of filings
are things called
Provisional Applications.
Provisionals are
very simple things.
They don't even
have to have claims.
They just describe
what the invention is.
And I've even seen people going
to give a paper at a talk slap
a cover page on it and file it.
And what it does
is it establishes
a filing date, which means
for the rest of the world,
you filed.
And you now have one
year from the date
you made the
provisional in order
to decide whether you really
want a patent on the thing
as you've tested out the market.
These are pretty inexpensive.
It's $130-- I checked the
other day-- for small entities.
And for micro entities,
which all of you would be,
it's $65 dollars.
Nothing happens at the
PTO once it's filed.
It's just a placeholder.
And the only risk is that
if you disclose something
in the provisional and when
you go to file the utility
patent a year later,
you include things
that weren't in the provisional,
you may have lost that.
So you have to sort
of think that through.
When we were developing the IP
Vision site as a SAS platform,
we were doing revs
every four to six weeks.
And for every release we'd
sit down and say, what is it
we did that might be of interest
that we might want to patent.
What did we think about
doing but we didn't actually
do because it wasn't in
the development plan.
We'd systematically do that and
we'd file provisional patents.
$100 a pop.
And it kept holding
our place until we
were ready to figure out what
we really wanted to patent
and spend the extra money on.
Was there a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, quick question.
You said that they slapped
a coverage fee on it.
[INAUDIBLE] That's then
publicly in the books.
So does that mean--
JOE HADZIMA: Oh sorry,
provisionals are not published.
AUDIENCE: But weren't they going
to present it at a conference,
you said?
JOE HADZIMA: They
may go disclose it.
AUDIENCE: Does that [INAUDIBLE]
an international patent
platform?
JOE HADZIMA: No, a provisional
counts as a filing.
AUDIENCE: For international?
JOE HADZIMA: For
international, yeah.
That's the good part
of the invention.
Now a patent lawyer will
say you're better off doing
a whole application and get the
claims and think it through.
Well, there's a lot of things
that would be good to do.
It's just time and resources.
So this is a reasonable
approach to think about.
As I say, it's all
fact dependent.
If you have something
that's really key
and you really understand
exactly what the invention is,
it might be worth going
directly to a full filing.
But it's just a strategy.
OK?
So what's in a patent.
How many people that
actually looked at a patent?
Read one?
Anyone have a patent?
Couple.
Good.
So it's sort of like a
term paper in a sense.
There's a part of it
that says, describe
to me what the invention is.
And again, it's a
societal trade off.
You tell me your invention,
I'll give you this limited time
monopoly.
So part of the usual set up is
there's a field of invention,
there's a background.
You usually describe what's
broken that you fixed.
To show why yours is novel
and nobody else has done it.
Non-obvious.
Then you summarize
the invention.
Then you go into a
detailed description.
And there's this
technical thing saying
you have to really explain what
the best mode of practicing
your invention is.
Because again, the idea
is if that knowledge gets
in a society, everybody
can build off of it
and we all get better.
And we give you the rights to
exclude for the 20 year period.
So you've got to really
actually describe how it works.
And then the claims
are the key part.
Now from a cost viewpoint,
I think everyone in the room
is capable of writing
everything about the patent
and save a bunch of money,
at least as a first draft.
You want the patent lawyers.
So the people that know
how to craft the claims.
The claims are the tricky part.
If you ever have to
enforce this stuff,
it's the claims
that really matter.
So that's where you want to
spend the legal money-- is
on the claims.
And if you just go in and
drop your lab notebook
on the patent
lawyer's desk, you're
paying by the hour for
stuff that you probably
are better off doing
yourself and doing
the first draft of what
it is you're trying to do.
Cost of-- US, an application
is about anywhere from $5,000
to $15,000 on average.
I've actually ended up
spending $30,000 because I
didn't control the process.
One of my co-founders kept
calling the patent lawyer
and throwing new things
in without telling me.
And then I get the bill.
I thought I had
the control on it.
The filing fee is not that much.
I should mention that
applications in the US
are now published 18
months after they're filed.
That is the official
utility application, not
the provisional.
So when you actually file your
full application, 18 months,
they're published.
And the only exception
is if you say,
I don't want to get a patent
any place else in the world,
then they will publish it in
the US until it actually issues,
if and when it issues.
Foreign applications
are really expensive.
There was a government
accounting office study
in the early 2000
era that looked
at 10 countries and an invention
by a relatively small entity.
And they estimated it would
cost somewhere between $300,000
and $500,000 to file
and maintain a patent
and in the 10 major countries.
So you want to be a little bit
thoughtful about this stuff.
Now I'm going to switch over
to university licensing.
And a little bit of history.
The federal government
sponsors a lot of research
all over the country.
And it used to be
the ownership of that
was the federal government and
somebody in Washington trying
to figure out what
was happening.
The Bayh-Dole Act came around
in 1980 and it said, look,
we're going to put licensing
down at the university level
where the research is done
because they'll have a better
idea of what's going on.
And we're going to
give them some rights
and some obligations.
So the key point here-- you can
look at it on the slide later--
is really putting it at
the university level.
There is some emphasis in
the rules about licensing
to small companies.
It used to be the big companies,
now the small companies.
And there's a provision for
royalties to inventors out
of the process.
Now at MIT it's the
Technology Licensing Office,
known as the TLO.
That is the place
that administers this.
Now the primary goal stated
by the TLO is tech transfer.
They want to get inventions
out into the marketplace.
And the secondary goal
is to generate revenue.
And there's the website
for checking it out.
Now, the secondary goal--
a lot of universities
seem to put the emphasis more
on the revenue side and less
on the tech transfer.
So MIT is a little
unique in this.
There's a question
of who owns stuff.
There's MIT IP Ownership Policy.
You can check us out at the TLO.
And essentially,
it says, look, MIT
is going to own the
work that's done here
by staff and researchers if
it's under funded research.
It will also own it if there's
a significant use of MIT
resources-- facilities.
So if you're using
the nuclear reactor.
It doesn't mean
that you're using
Athena or stuff like that.
But if you're using
significant use,
then MIT may claim ownership.
If you have questions
about ownership,
the TLO is pretty approachable.
So you can go over and
chat with them about it.
And they often will
waive or clarify rights
to enable you to
start your company.
What you don't want to
do is go down the path,
get investors interested,
and then have them,
again, find out that
maybe you don't actually
have rights to the stuff.
That's not a good place to be.
Now this place has got a
lot of smart people doing
a lot of interesting things.
And not all of it falls
under the sponsored research
or significant
use of facilities.
So MIT actually
has a policy that
says we will voluntarily
look at and maybe
take on board inventions
the people have.
Even if it wasn't
under funded research.
And what they'll do is so
prosecute the patent around
and engage in licensing.
So that's opened up the number
of things that the TLO does.
And they're pretty
open about it.
Now as a startup,
what can you do.
Licensing can be expensive.
You're trying to
put a plan together,
you're trying to
figure out your market,
you want to secure the
rights, and you need funding.
So typically what
happens is you'll get
an option on the technology.
We'll call it just
technology broadly.
It's usually six
months to a year.
It's not that expensive.
You'll have to assume some of
the patent prosecution costs.
And what it allows
you to do-- that is,
to know-- that when
you take the idea out
to the investor community,
you actually can fulfill.
You've got everything lined up.
I've got rights to the patents.
I've got my idea, I've got my
team, I just need your money.
And away you go.
Typical license terms.
This is a couple years
old, care of Steve Brown,
who used to be at the TLO.
The components of the license
you'll find include issue fees.
In other words, what does
it cost to actually get
the license directly.
There's maintenance
fees to continue
to maintain the license.
There's diligence.
They don't want you
to just sit on it.
And what I've done
in the columns here
is if you don't want
to give up equity,
what the typical terms are, and
what the terms are with equity.
Royalty as a percentage of sale.
You see 3% to 5% with no equity.
2% to 4%, maybe with.
Patent costs are
the same, et cetera.
Now from equity side, one
of the big innovations
that MIT did is-- it used
to be only big companies
would come in and license.
But we look here and all the
entrepreneurial stuff going on.
They said, well we want
to figure out a way
to encourage small companies.
And so how do we do that.
Well the equity was
one way to do it.
And we'll take equity in
lieu of the cash fees.
Typically it's single
digit percentage of equity
that you give up.
And that percentage is
maintained undiluted, usually
through the first major
round of financing.
And we'll talk
about what dilution
means when we get into
terms here in a little bit.
These were typical
royalties a few years ago
for university patents.
You'll see they're
all over the place.
Again, it's in the materials.
You can check those out.
Now how do they have
split things up.
Just so you have
an appreciation.
If there is any
return from a license,
be it royalties or a
company goes public
and MIT sells the
stock, 15% percent
comes off the top to pay
for TLO operating expenses.
Than they deduct
the patent costs.
And then after that, a third
of it goes to the inventors.
And then basically, with
some other adjustments,
the other two thirds are split
between the department and MIT
in general.
So that's a
university licensing.
Any questions on that?
OK, really do approach the TLO.
They're pretty responsive.
Or they can be.
AUDIENCE: Can you
kind of name some
of the pitfalls of some
[INAUDIBLE] something
out of the lab, and
not necessarily-- like
when to sever ties
with the research lab
and make sure you have
a really strong wall
between the two and [INAUDIBLE]
JOE HADZIMA: Yeah there's
a whole bunch of things.
So the basic strategy is
that if you're funded,
you get your license, and
you set up shop outside,
and the people that are at
MIT go across the street
and do their work in
the lab or whatever.
Across the street,
not on MIT campus.
And that sort of
works the same way
if you're starting a company.
That you try to
separate the two.
Now it gets a little complex if
you're under sponsored research
and you're being
funded in a lab.
It can get a little complex.
We had a situation a few years
ago back when I was practicing.
Where my client was a
professor in the AI,
artificial intelligence group,
and one of his PhD students
was split between the
Media Lab and the AI group.
And because of the way the
Media Lab stuff worked,
the professors
inventions were somehow
being claimed by the Media Lab.
So there's some real
technical stuff there.
But there are plenty of people
who can help you out on that.
And I just want to
put a red flag up.
Again, to think about it.
In terms of whether you
can actually own it,
the TLO can be
approachable on that.
OK, now I want to switch
to the next topic, which is
legal forms of doing business.
How do you get organized.
And again, these are sort of
the red flag kind of things.
I'm going to cut through.
I do a whole couple of sessions
at Sloan on this stuff.
But here I'm going to try
to give you the high level
conclusions.
So in most cases
for companies that
are technology
based companies that
are going to need any
kind of financing,
the choice is a
Delaware corporation.
Delaware has a
corporate law that's
very flexible,
predictable, and it
has its separate court that
hears specific cases surround
stockholder rights.
And so the default tends
to be towards Delaware.
And the question is, when
should you incorporate.
Or should you incorporate.
Basically, the corporation
gives you limited liability
as owners of the business.
You can't say, look,
I've got this idea.
I'm going to set
up a company, I'll
transfer my invention
to the company,
and I won't have any
personal liability.
You're always liable
for your own acts.
The question here, from
launching a company viewpoint,
is are your investors going
to be liable for your acts.
So that's where corporate form
protects the shareholders.
Now the question is
when to incorporate.
You should do it
sooner than later
to avoid personal liability
based on your ownership
and toward
partnership liability.
And there's a thing I'm going to
go into called the Section 83.
And that's a real catch for
you if you don't work on it
and incorporate early.
Now the next question
is, all right,
I got a corporate
form, how is it taxed.
And again, the default
that I always recommend
is to file what's called
an S corporation election.
So a regular corporation
is taxed on its profit.
And when that profit is handed
out to the shareholders,
it's taxed again.
So there's two layers of tax.
A Subchapter S, if you qualify--
there's only one layer of tax.
The corporation doesn't pay tax.
But the attributes get passed
through to the shareholders.
You have to have fewer
than 100 shareholders.
One class of stock.
And you can't have
nonresident aliens
as shareholders, which
is an issue if you're
a foreign student.
And it has to be
primarily human beings,
except for certain
types of trusts.
So as soon as a
venture capital firm--
if you take the money-- invests,
it'll destroy the Subchapter S
status and it'll
be taxed as a C.
But it can really
make a difference.
The first company that was
taken out of the Media Lab
was a company called DIVA,
Digital Video Applications.
And the founder said, if we
don't ever get venture money,
we'll never succeed.
And I said, well let's do
it with the S corporation.
Well they never did
raise venture money.
They sold the company
two years later
for I think it was somewhere
around $10 million.
And they saved a million and a
half or more having done that.
Let me move through here.
Here's an example of the
S corporation taxation.
I'll just leave it in there.
You can see the
two layers of tax.
And the net effect is,
well why would you do this
if most startups lose money.
They're not going to be taxed.
And the issue is
it's when it gets
acquired that you can succeed.
And you can save 20 plus
percent under current rates.
You can work the math from
the slides that are online.
Now I want to switch to
something that is actually
an issue for you personally.
And it can be a big thing.
It's a very odd part
of the Internal Revenue
code called Section 83.
And it says, if you receive
property in connection
with providing
services- and here stock
is property for this purpose--
then you have ordinary income.
That's like you get when
you get a paycheck, which
can be taxed up to 35 plus
percent under current rates.
And the amount is the fair
market value of the property
that you get, minus
what you paid.
And that's what the income
is that you pay tax on.
So here's an example.
I like your idea.
And I say, I'll tell
you what, I'll give you
a million dollars, we'll start
a company, and how about 50-50.
And you say, OK.
For this purpose, you say 50-50.
What happens is, let
me ask you how much
is your 50% of the company.
I provide the capital,
a million dollars,
we each have 50% of the company,
and you get the other 50%,
how much is your side worth.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: What's the [INAUDIBLE]
JOE HADZIMA: I put the
first million dollars
in for half the company.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOE HADZIMA: Yeah, it
could be a million or--
AUDIENCE: $750,000.
JOE HADZIMA: $750,000.
Well you could say
it's a million,
because why would I pay
a million for one half
if the other half
wasn't worth a million.
On the other hand, once the
million dollars goes in,
and there's no real asset in
there other than the million
dollars, you sort of own
half the million dollars.
So let's just do the math.
So the fair market value, if it
was at $500,000, you pay zero,
your ordinary income
is $500,000 taxed
at 35% percent or something.
Not good.
And if it's a million, 40%
would be $200,000 you owe.
And if it's a million,
you owe $400,000.
Congratulations.
Tax bill.
So that's not a
good result, right?
So the question is,
how do you avoid that.
Well the trick is
to separate the time
when you get your stock from the
time the investment comes in.
So if you come in to a
lawyer's office on Friday
with a term sheet and
say, let's incorporate,
we're going to close
next week, the question
is, what happened between
Friday and when you closed.
Well maybe a patent
issued or you
got FDA approval or something.
So you stretch those
further in time
and you get your
stock early then
you don't fall into this trap.
It's when you get your
stock at the same time
the investment comes in.
So the mission here is to
incorporate earlier and issue
stock as soon as you
can and make what's
called an 83(b) election, which
we won't go into fully here,
but you have to do
that within 30 days.
So the question is, why doesn't
stock get issued in time.
Even with startups.
I see so many situations
where the team is working,
they're doing all the things
that guys up here talked about.
And the investment comes
in and they may even
have incorporated, but
they haven't actually
given the stock out.
And I think it could be anything
from too busy to nobody's quite
sure who should get what.
You heard John
talk about everyone
pulling their weight
except one person.
What I do see in the case
of technical startups
is the issue between
the technologists
who maybe has the idea--
so think of the dynamics.
We're starting a company.
We've got to sort of prove out
the technology with a prototype
or something.
And the technologist
is working in the lab.
Working really hard
on it, long hours.
And the business side people
are waiting, maybe even
keep their day job
doing the planning.
And there's sort
of this dichotomy.
So if you think
about it this way.
If you say I have time
across a horizontal axis
and relative importance.
And I said, where would you
put the technology person
on this chart at the beginning.
How relatively important
is the technology
in a start up at the beginning.
Well it's going to be high,
because if it doesn't work
you don't have anything.
And where would you
put the business guy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOE HADZIMA: Well
over time, technology
is less important, right?
Relatively speaking.
And the business starts at the
bottom, relatively speaking,
and improves over time.
And at some point,
they're balanced off.
Whether they cross or not
isn't really important.
The important
thing is to realize
you can have team dynamics
where the technology people, who
think it's their
invention, they're
doing all the
work-- and then how
do you end up splitting stock
in a situation like that.
Well it's my technology,
I don't want to give it.
You guys aren't really doing it.
And you get a lot of
tension around that.
But just simply
realizing the dynamics
of relative importance.
And you heard from
the people here
about needing a
whole team to pull
it off can at least put people
in the same way of thinking
about it.
Does that make sense?
OK.
Now what you heard from
the have the team here
tonight that people
was the most important.
And most companies fail
because of people issues.
So you got to sort out
those relationships upfront.
Now in a small company,
the stockholders
owe each other a fiduciary duty.
Meaning you got a
sort of treat everyone
with a degree of fairness.
So you'll have a
set of questions
about who sits on the board.
If you populate a board other
than for legal, who owes what
titles, what functional things.
You want to talk
about restrictions
on stock transfers.
Rights of first refusal,
tag along rights,
all of these terms
here you can read
about in the founders memo,
which is in the resources
part of the website.
This is a memo that years
ago-- I had one week,
as a relatively young lawyer,
and I had three teams come in.
Great startup teams from MIT.
And with each team I
spent four to five hours
with them trying to walk them
through the kind of things
that you need to think about.
So at the end of the week I'm
thinking, this is ridiculous.
I went through the same set of
exercises with these people.
They don't want to
pay me to do this.
I don't want to spend all
the time educating them.
So I went home and I wrote
the beginning or the Founder's
Memo, which sort of sets out
all of the kind of things
to think about.
And what I would do after
that is, I would say,
if you're going to come
in and meet with me,
I want you all to
read the founders memo
and start talking about
what philosophy you have
and understand
some of the issues.
So we don't spend a lot
of time educating you
while the meter's running.
And that worked
very effectively.
So the Founder's Memo--
it's not a fancy memo
but it's been very helpful
to people over the years
they tell me.
So the question is how to
founder's equity split.
The Wasserman book is a good one
to look out on different ways
founders think about splitting.
There's no one formula.
There's a culture.
I negotiated Kenan Systems.
It was a very successful company
sold for a billion dollars.
It was owned by one
person, Kenan Sahin.
He paid all of his
people good salaries.
And that culture worked.
It was a very
successful company.
He ended up giving $100
million to MIT, which was nice.
But it doesn't mean
that you always
have to spread equity around.
And part of this is
from Charlie's slides.
You're going to look at the
value of past contributions
and future contributions.
Sacrifice commitment.
Ownership of IP.
People's internal or
external market value.
And internal equity.
There was a good
team that was set up
that went through a really
disciplined exercise
where there was at MIT
professor and a post-doc.
And they were trying to
figure out how to split it up.
So I said to each
of them, well you
write down what you think you're
giving up to join the company.
And we just have a
discussion about it.
So the professor
said, well, I've
got a worldwide reputation.
I'm allowed to consult
one day a week.
If I joined the company, I'm
not going to be doing that.
My consulting rate is x.
And he had a bunch of things.
The post-doc said, well, I'll
be giving up my academic career.
It would be very hard
for me to go back.
If I got a job in industry,
I'd be making this much.
I'm going to be spending
full time on this.
And it created a
framework where they
could have a discussion around
how they were approaching it.
It was fairly successful.
And that works often with MIT.
People were sort of data driven.
The other thing about
equity-- when you get beyond--
I'll mention it in a moment.
We're going to switch
over now to employees
and outside contractors.
This is the slide from
Charlie the other night.
He included in here
about how to think
about equity with employees.
One of the issues with employees
is does stock motivate.
Does it really motivate.
If you've never actually
been in a company
and had an event occur
where that piece of paper
was enough money to buy a
nice car or a down payment
on a house or something--
it's just a piece of paper.
The first job I had out of MIT
was with a spin-off company
from Pugh-Roberts.
Ed Roberts at Sloan School.
We were in a triple decker
house up on [? Leigh ?] Street.
I was the third employee.
We had the third floor
because his other company
was on the nice floors.
And so the first
day I get there,
I come sort of mid
morning, it's time.
I've got to go down, use the
bathroom after all a coffee.
So the bathroom was
one of those half baths
under the stairway under
these triple decker houses.
So I go down there, I open
the door, and I look in.
And the entire wall
this little half bath
is papered with what looks
like real stock certificates.
I mean first of all, I
thought it was wallpaper.
That's sort of a
weird wallpaper.
Then I looked.
They're real stock certificates.
So clearly they weren't
worth a whole lot if they
were wallpapering a bathroom.
So to me it said two things.
One is if you don't want
to work for wallpaper,
get back to work.
And secondly, what is
this stuff called stock.
So a lot of employees-- you
shouldn't assume right away
that equity motivates people.
People don't understand
it many cases.
There was a story about
Prime Computer and Bose,
where they were
recruiting an engineer.
And they basically had
the same cash salary.
But one company was
offering twice as much stock
as the other-- number of shares.
And what was not clear was that
they had the same market value.
One stock was worth twice as
much per share as the other.
So the perception, if you're
not used to dealing with stock,
that people automatically
understand how it works.
You shouldn't assume.
There is a market for labor if
you're in certain industries--
you're going to
need to give equity
to bring in the good people.
But you really have
to think about that.
Don't just go pattern
thinking about.
Oh everyone gets
stock because that's
the way everyone does things.
You have to think about that.
So the question is if
you're starting a company
and you're going
out and let's say
you're successful in raising
some outside money, what
fraction of the equity goes into
the equity compensation pool.
Well Charlie had
that nice template
for financial projections.
And he had a head count.
And as you recall, he matched
the head count to equity
based on the type of position.
And the initial stock
pool for companies
is usually two to three years
worth of the head count plan.
Now what does that translate
if your venture-backed.
In my experience, at first
round venture financing,
you're probably going to have
somewhere between 12% and 18%
of the total equity
reserved for employees.
It'll be at the
lower end of that
if you've got more of
your team fleshed out.
It'll be at the higher end or
even higher if it's just you
and you've got to
hire in some people.
But that's a reasonable
rule of thumb.
And for most equity
plans, you're
going to think about
employees, directors, and maybe
consultants.
And if you try to
calibrate this,
there are surveys
and places you can
go to see what the market is
for different types of equity
grants.
Again, from Charlie's
slides, just as
a reminder in one place.
These were some
ownership percentages
he talked about after
two rounds of financing.
And you will always end
up granting more later
to keep people incented.
This was his spreadsheet
with dilution showing.
I just put it here
for reference.
[? Yonald ?] is going
to do a great job
on the last night
of the class where
he's going to walk you
through what actually happened
to employees and
founders and investors.
So I think we'll let him get
into that in more detail.
Now we'll run through common
forms of equity compensation.
There's restricted stock.
And there are two
types of options.
One is an incentive
stock option,
which has certain tax benefits
and their non-qualified.
Again, restricted stock is
stock that's granted to somebody
or sold to somebody and it
starts a capital gains holding
period for tax and SCC.
It's usually subject to vesting.
Charlie talked about vesting.
And you may want to file
an 83(b) election because
of the vesting.
You can read more about
that in the Founder's Memo.
Incentive stock
options are options
to comply with tax requirements.
They're granted
only to employees.
And they have to be
granted at an exercise
price that's fair market value.
What does that mean.
That means you can buy
100 shares of stock
at today's price.
And the theory is that
hopefully, over time the stock
goes up.
Maybe it's $10 exercised and
when a person exercises it,
it's $100.
So they pay $10 and they
get stock worth $100.
And those exercise vesting
occur over time, typically.
And there's no tax on it.
You're not taxed when
you get the stock.
There may be an alternative
minimum tax issue.
Again, a placeholder
for you to think about.
And there will be taxation
on the sale of the stock.
And if you end up following
the holding period,
you'll have capital gains,
which is a good thing.
And that's one year
from the exercise
and two years from
the date of grant.
And non-qualified
are basically options
that have no tax on
vesting or grant,
but ordinary income on exercise.
So that means when you
exercise the difference
between the exercise price
and the fair market value,
you have to pay-- it's
like somebody gave you
that much cash.
Now these instruments of
founder stock, restricted stock
options, and non-qualifieds all
work together in sort of a way.
What you really would like to
do if you're a founder or early
on, you actually want to get
your stock early and then ride
the appreciation.
Just like you'd buy any
stock in the market.
What happens though if
you're given stock--
you have income when
you get the stock
based on the market value.
So over time, as the company
raises more rounds of funding,
it becomes more
expensive for someone
to actually acquire
the stock directly.
And since there's no
market for the stock,
you're in a situation
where you're
taxed on the stock but no exit.
You have no way to pay it.
So that's when people
switch over and use options.
Because options-- you're not
taxed when you get an option.
You sort of control
when the tax occurs.
So that's just a general
theme to think about.
Vesting.
There are basically
two types of vesting.
Time-based vesting and
performance vesting.
What you're really trying to
do is you go into it thinking,
well, we have a set of
things we need to get done.
And you want to provide
incentives for people to do it.
And so in an ideal
world you'd know
exactly what needed to be done.
And you'd say, when you
deliver the first prototype,
you vest on and
50% of your option.
And when we do our first
customer ship, another 25%.
The problem is it's
never that clean.
You're never quite sure.
And so the default
tends to be time.
We're going to be in this
for a period of time.
If you're here pulling
on the oar with a team,
then you'll vest.
Typical vesting is
a one year cliff.
That means if you're
here less than a year you
don't get anything.
After one year it's usually 25%.
And then it's either monthly or
quarterly over the next three
years.
So at the end of four
years, you're fully vested
and have rights in the stock.
I put something in here
about accelerated vesting
on changing control.
You'll hear about that.
And there are a whole bunch
of issues about whether that
makes any sense.
So keep that in mind.
You have to think about what
happens if someone leaves.
You gave them this equity and
do you get to buy it back.
Do they forfeit it.
What if they leave
under bad circumstances
where they gave
away trade secrets.
And what if they violate
non-competition agreements.
So you probably want
to think about those
in the design of your plan.
And again, think of
this as a checklist
when you're dealing with
your lawyer on this.
Have they talked
about these things.
Now suppose you actually
have the stock and you leave.
What's the deal.
Do you get to keep
it when you leave.
Do you have to sell it
back at then fair value.
Never.
I mean, these are
philosophical issues
that the Founder's
Memo talks about.
And at the beginning
is a good time
to talk about it
because you don't
know who's going to be leaving.
So it's sort of a
neutral thing about what
your philosophy is going to be.
Over time, on a people
issue, at the beginning
the whole issue of boards-- I
put independent directors here.
Somewhere around the
time of first funding.
Funding people are
going to want to come in
and the venture
capitalists actually
do have to get some board
seats under the rules
that they operate under.
There's often an
independent director
that they'll negotiate.
So you want to be
thinking ahead.
Who's an independent director
that could be on my board
and acceptable to venture.
Because if you don't
have a candidate in mind
they certainly
will talk about it.
OK, financing.
I'm going to run you quickly
through securities laws.
Essentially, this
is an area you don't
want to try to do brain
surgery yourself with.
You can get into
really big troubles.
Any offer or even an
offer of securities
has to be registered with
the Securities and Exchange
Commission.
And that could be a big
expensive proposition.
So you want to think
about exemptions.
There are exemptions there
for private placements.
And there's certain
rules you have
to do in following it through.
What you don't want
to do is-- question
is, if you don't comply,
what is the big deal.
Well, first of all, it's
criminal-- can be criminal.
And it could be personal
liability on the founder.
In other words, they can get
their money back from you.
And it could be a mess.
And in the materials,
under Resources, there's
a column I did for Boston
Business Journal that
talked about a company that
really got into bad trouble
because they screwed up on this.
So my red letter
thing here is, don't,
in a business plan, put
language in that offers to sell.
We're offering 10% of the
company for $2 million.
How do you say
that's not an offer.
So the business plan or
any of the documents,
really, is this
is an opportunity.
We're addressing this market.
The market's this big.
And you might say, and
the resources we need
is this amount.
If people are
interested in that,
they're going to have a
conversation with you.
And you can handle
it in a careful way.
But I see over and over again,
people putting in plans.
First of all, it's
presumptuous, right?
Have a discussion
with the investor
and you can get
down the numbers.
But certainly don't
put it in the plan.
We do have now
crowdfunding coming along.
We're waiting for some SEC
rules to get a little bit more
refined.
That's going to open up a
whole other set of issues.
But it may be a good way-- just
like crowdfunding for products
has been around-- this is
crowdfunding for selling stock
or interest in the company.
I don't know enough
yet to explain how
that's going to work for you.
But keep an eye on
that separately.
I put in a section in the deck
looking at capital structure
instruments.
For some people,
this is old hat.
For the people that
aren't, this is
something you should look at.
It just talks about different
kinds of instruments.
At the bottom is common stock.
Common stock is what's the
value after everyone else has
gotten paid.
So if you're Bill Gates and you
own common stock in Microsoft,
you're like the richest
guy in the world.
If you're a startup, this
might be worth nothing.
Above it are
different instruments
that you can play with.
And for the non-Sloan
people, take a look
at the next few slides
that describe this.
I'm just going to zip
through them, given the time.
This visual just shows
what a capital structure
will look like over time.
At a startup, it's
primarily all common.
And by the time you're
Microsoft or an LBO,
you see more complex
capital structures.
That's your instant
MBA course for people
not in the MBA program.
We talked about convertible
note financing the other night.
Traditionally this bridged
from one round to another
as you were trying to
keep the company going.
It has the benefit of being
quick, relatively inexpensive,
and it can avoid
valuation issues.
So a classic problem
is the first run
investors value the
company too high.
The next round
comes in and says,
we're never going to pay
that much because things
have happened or whatever.
And the first round has to
have this discussion-- how
they get crammed down in their
percentage of the company.
Convertible note allows
you to sort of not
set that actual
valuation until later.
There's a good
discussion of this
at startupcompanylawyer.com,
which
talks about the pros and cons.
So again, another
resource to look at.
This is an example
of a term sheet.
If you go to firms--
like Cooly LLP
has a nice, open
source models of what
the documents look like.
There's also some good
resources at Wilson Sonsini
and at Goodwin Procter.
Much more accessible these
days than they were back
when I was starting out.
Now we're going to run quickly
through angel and venture
funding.
A typical way to do this
is you take a term sheet
and you take it
apart and you talk
about each of the little
components of the term sheet.
And that's a useful
way to do it.
I think the way
for an entrepreneur
to think about why all these
terms is to understand what
the major deal elements are.
And from an investor viewpoint,
it's these four elements.
One is a preferred return,
for reasons we'll talk about.
Protection of valuation and
position versus future money
that comes in.
The requirement to manage
the investment and the exit
strategy.
So for example, if you
think a preferred return,
an investor looks at you and
he sees a plan or a promise.
The investor writes a check.
The investor has
basically done everything
that he said he would do.
He'll be there to
advise and all that.
But basically he'll
want his money.
The entrepreneur
hasn't done anything
from the investor perspective.
They put together a plan
that's yet to be executed on.
And so the result is
the investor typically
wants to get paid before
the entrepreneur gets paid.
He gets his money back first.
And the instrument is usually
the convertible preferred
stock.
It usually has dividends.
And an important part is
the liquidation preference.
So the liquidation
preference says,
look, there are two types.
One is a straight preference.
It says, if the company-- we
have a liquidation-- which I'll
talk about what that means
in a moment-- the investor
can either choose
to get the money he
put in back pluses dividends.
Or you can convert, because
it's usually convertible,
into whatever the convertible
amount of the company would be.
So it's simply a math exercise.
That's a straight
liquidation preference.
A participating or
double dip is one
that's not particularly good in
many cases for an entrepreneur.
It says the investor
gets his money back first
and then he converts and
pretends he was like you
and gets a percentage
of the company.
I put a chart in comparing
how that math works.
I think it's pretty
self explanatory if you
look at it in the materials.
And I put a case in
here which says--
there are two cases presented.
One is, a founder sells 40%
of the company for $5 million
of convertible preferred,
with a $5 million
liquidation preference.
But no participating rights.
In Case B, they sell
33% of the company
with participating preferred.
And this example shows
you the trade off.
Essentially, in this
case, if the exit
is $35 million or less,
than the first case
is better for the founders,
which means actually
giving up a bigger
percentage of the company
and having a straight preferred.
So take a look at
that after class.
The liquidation events
could be really liquidation,
meaning the company's shut down.
But it's often defined
to be a merger.
So if the company is acquired,
the liquidation kicks in.
That's the preferred
return part as you
look through the term sheet.
The second major
element is protection
of value and position
versus future money
and that's where anti-dilution
protection comes in.
And I give you an example
of a term sheet with that.
Anti-dilution and
conversion go hand in hand.
So typically, a
convertible-preferred
trades one for one.
One share of preferred
converts to one share
of common at the beginning.
And anti-dilution
says, if an event
occurs in which you issue
stock for less money
or priced less
than price I paid,
then when I convert I
want to get more shares.
Because your value of
the company's gone down.
I came in at this level
and you did something.
You didn't grow the company,
you made the value go down,
and therefore I need
to get compensated.
And the two main types of
these is the full ratchet,
which is really bad
for an entrepreneur.
That says if I issue
even one share of stock
for less money than what
you, the investor, put in,
then the price of that
one share of stock
becomes a conversion price.
So if I converted at $10 a share
and you issued one share at $1,
now all my money
converts at $1 a share.
So I get 10 times more.
The more typical one is
the weighted average.
And there's a formula
for that that.
It looks at the
price and the amount.
On the resources page there
are a bunch of venture capital
terms that will help
explain a lot of what
we went through here.
And that brings us
to borrow, which
is we're going to go into
negotiation skills, in Yost
you're doing organization
and people issues.
Tomorrow?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOE HADZIMA: So I raced
you through a whole bunch
of legal stuff that we
could have spend hours
on each portion of it.
Again, I want to step back,
say, take the deck that's there,
read through it, and use
it as sort of a guidepost
as you go forward on
some of the stuff.
There are plenty of resources
that I've mentioned that you
can sort of self educate.
I'm happy to chat with you
offline about those things.
I know no other way to get
it out in front of you,
short of having you take
a whole legal course.
So hopefully you'll find that.